what is up everybody it's animag here
for anime uproar
and today i will be addressing the
latest insane twist
in the black clover story new top class
devils were just revealed
in black clover and yami's life is now
in imminent danger as the entire plan to
rescue him
unravels following the most recent story
events
this was so unexpected and so crazy the
stakes have never been higher
so let's get into it if you enjoyed the
blacklord content here on the channel
and you want us to keep it going you
know what to do
leave that like it only takes a second
but it really does help
and if you're new to the channel or
maybe you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video do subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter and instagram
at anime uproar finally this video will
of course contain black lover manga
spoilers
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned
the latest installment of the story
starts off with mario leona
absolutely scorching and deep-frying
that
giant ancient demon outside the palace
marillana is having a blast and she even
seems disappointed that the giant demon
wasn't
more of a challenge meanwhile members of
the spade kingdom resistance are shocked
that one mage could defeat such a
creature
all on her own but that's our uncrowned
undefeated lioness literally the hottest
waifu in black
clover meanwhile ralph finally meets up
with members of the resistance and ralph
is accompanied by
sally valtos radiss makusa north
and the one and only demon king seki
with both meroleona and sekke right
there in one place
it's safe to say that the villains don't
stand a chance in hell
although speaking of hell a massive
twist suddenly occurs
inside the palace a twist that changes
everything
and puts the entire plan to save yami
and william in jeopardy
at first it looks like all the fights
against the dark triad are going pretty
well
and knocked comments that the clover
kingdom mages are stronger than he
thought
he also says that they still have enough
time before the tree of clifforth
opens so they should be able to stop the
ritual and save william and yami without
too much trouble
but then the mages inside the palace
feel a powerful
and ominous sensation and in the very
next moment
dark branches and roots begin enveloping
the entire palace
much to the shock of everyone inside and
outside the palace
knocked uses devil union form with
another one of his devils the one who
looks like a little cat
and apparently his name is plumede
knocked then uses a shadow magic spell
called clairvoyant
to see right down to the cliff off
doorway he senses another mana there
aside from yami and william and it is
soon revealed that morris
is also down there morris explains that
vanica's decision to kidnap loro pachika
ended up being very useful to him
because
through loropichika he was able to
access the wisdom of the heart
kingdom and so using this wisdom he has
figured out a way to accelerate
the growth of the cliff off that means
that morris has been able to speed up
the timeline of the ritual
and so knocked estimations for how much
time they had before the clifford opens
just went right out the window morris
also reveals that he was born
blind but at some point he also became
possessed
by a devil and using devil magic he was
able to forcibly extract lord
chica's wisdom from her and implant it
into himself
noct isn't sure why exactly this is
happening
but morris appears to be some sort of
catalyst for opening the gate of
clifforth and because of this
their time is quickly running out
the cliff off the doorway to the
underworld the world of the devils
is already opening noc decides that he
should take out morris as soon as
possible but unfortunately for noct and
everyone else from the clover kingdom
and the spade resistance
it is already too late two unknown
devils
emerge from the ground and make their
appearance on the main
battlefield one appears to be female and
the other appears to be male
and they both look extremely creepy but
also extremely cool
everyone is shocked to see these two
strange entities
and a visibly nervous knock acknowledges
that these two
are top class devils just like lucifer
they are among the strongest devils in
existence
as the two devils remark that everything
is getting interesting now
this insane chapter comes to an end
whoa now according to the tree of cliff
off illustration that we've seen
in the past there are two devils on the
very top level
of the tree so these must be those
two devils that means that the cliff off
has already been opened well ahead of
schedule
and well before knocked was expecting it
to open wow
i was not expecting this to happen so
soon
and morris has definitely surprised me i
thought that he was just a mad scientist
side character and his whole role in the
story would be doing some experiments
and making the dark
triad stronger but no there seems to be
more
to this guy apparently he is also
possessed by a devil
and he managed to find a way to throw a
massive wrench
into knox rescue plan so clearly morris
is more than just some random mad
scientist
side character that doesn't really
matter i can't wait to find out more
about morris
and about his true intentions i bet that
the other mad scientist
in the story our girl sally is going to
have some sort of
showdown with morris during this arc
there has to be a good reason why tabata
chose to include sally
on this mission and my guess is that it
has something to do with
morris personally i'm excited to learn
more about
morris's insane master plan
now in terms of the two devils first up
they definitely look
both cool and creepy and when i first
saw them appear not gonna lie
i kind of got goosebumps these two
devils are really fascinating because in
some ways they almost look like two
halves of one hole for instance one of
the devils has a large demonic right arm
and the other has a large demonic left
arm one has a dark mask on the right
side of its face
and the other has a dark mask on the
left side of its face
the two devils also look very similar
although one appears to have breasts
while the other doesn't
and that is why i am assuming that one
is male and the other is female
if that assumption is correct then this
is our first confirmation that there
are indeed female devils up to this
point we didn't know whether devils had
a gender at all
since we don't know how they reproduce
but if this
is confirmation that female devils exist
then it might tell us more about the
devils as a species
also if female devils exist then the
whole community is going to be talking
about devil waifus for weeks
and months to come which i guess will
also be pretty fun
at the very end of the chapter these two
devils mention that things are now
interesting and that makes sense because
we know from liebe's backstory that the
underworld is very boring and so most of
the devils want to find a way
up to the human world because things are
more fun there and much more interesting
i wonder if liebe knows these two devils
in particular and if so i wonder if they
have some personal devil drama between
them
i have seen some people pointing out
that the one giant hand
that each of these devils possesses
looks a lot like the giant hand that
threw liebe
up into the human world in the first
place so we'll have to wait and see if
one of these two devils
is actually the devil who threw liba up
into the human world
definitely let me know what you guys
think about these devils
do you like their design and what do you
think is their relationship to each
other
are they maybe brother and sister was
one of them
the ticked off higher devil who threw
liba up
into the human world personally i do
like their design a lot
and i'm excited to see them in action
it's probably safe to assume that these
two devils are both stronger than zagred
in which case this will be an extremely
difficult battle
they also look like siblings or
something along those lines
so they probably have some extremely
advanced teamwork skills
even though the clover kingdom mages
have had some serious power ups since
they fought
the great it will not be easy to take
these devils down but with that said
we do have to remember that even though
these are top class
devils they are still on the very top of
the cliff off
and we already know that the lower you
go the stronger the devils become
lucifer is the devil at the very bottom
so compared to him
these guys might still be pretty weak
still
it's crazy to think that the clover
kingdom mages and the resistance
now have to take on the dark triad
morris
and these two top class devils without
the help of
osta and liba they better get mere leona
and the demon lord sekke into the palace
right away because they need some
serious backup like
right now by the way do you think that
yami and williams lives
could be in real danger now that the
cliff fog has been opened
or do you think that they're going to be
saved in the end let me know
down below if you enjoyed the blacklord
content here on the channel and you want
us to keep it going please don't forget
to leave that like
it really does help and if you're new to
anime uproar or you haven't subscribed
yet
make this the video do you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications it's annoying but you
really have to go through the trouble of
hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
gonna miss a ton of our videos even if
you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons who make videos like this
one possible
special thanks to alpha sigma disciple
of lord twego himself
and i can't forget our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above
all other clans including ingrata
the world acquired respect pate heffa
dr cortman ruthie and y x emperor otaku
spotty life canal big buddhist and
tungsten tarkis
finally thank you to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers
angel cruz anatoly kazatsky joe stanton
very gucci jessica kayla font rathun
deora alicia octor
bonnie park sinokami and water the
red-haired raven florian joanne garcia
jack watches anime fat boy games deadly
saint matthew crews anthony schreiber hi
jinx and mr waffles 247.
if you feel that our videos provide
value for you consider supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patreon exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you